In the last lesson we learned that linear factors of polynomials tell us about
x-intercepts of the graphs that go along with those polynomials. So if we have
an equation like y equals x minus 3 times x plus 1 It's going to have x
intercepts of three, zero, and negative one zero. So this is a big part of our
motivation for talking about factoring so much. If we can factor a polynomial
then we already know all of the places where it hits the x axis. We learned
before the linear factors of a polynomial tell us about where the polynomial
hits the x axis. On the last quiz, we learned that x squared plus one is not
factorable, however, I'm going to expand our statement about x squared plus one
and tell you that it is not only not factorable, but it actually has no real
linear factors. I know that we're not totally clear on what this means yet, and
you'll learn in a few lessons. But let's just explore this briefly for now,
touch on it a bit. Considering this, how many places do you think on the graph
of y equals x squared plus one touches the x axis?